hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play it's hurting
my eyes ok someone recommended to this
me to me very strongly so when I was
downloading it didn't seem like anything
that I've seen before an an amnesia
custom story so I'm pretty sure that
it's just me being delusional from being
very tired today or this is just a
ridiculous custom story so another your
story even if I slide down a deep
darkened path and I skinned my in my
knees I have got to stand right back up
I've got to take my chance now before I
let it get way bigger
big and bigger biggest dreamer dreams
are only the start to everything that
has an answer and a beginning I will fly
faster with my wings if I use all my
strength throughout all the today's and
tomorrow's how very
[Music]
okay any day now this would be perfectly
fine to let me actually play the game
that would be lovely come on come on
there we go finally geez come on okay
okay okay I'll ride out right out right
what have we got all right okay this
doesn't look like anything that I've
ever seen before in my entire life in
amnesia or anything else for that matter
but okay let's press on I'm sure this
will be great foods birds bees wild
flowers and sturdy little shrubs English
gardeners must be using so same crystal
balls we are here in the North West in
an article the predictions of leading
Brit gardeners sound familiar except
that their garden centres are
flourishing and they remain
shell-shocked after suffering through
the wettest summer ever the old acer
grocery VAR hare see fell over
unexpectedly although stefan and had
noticed the tree seemed to be declining
but he had no idea the roots were rotted
away it's a reminder to loosen and
spread roots of any containerized
pre-plan and they'll just continue to
circle in on themselves and not plunge
more deeply and widely into the soil so
the tree can support itself as it grows
what thousand like the most what what
the most what's all right okay this
makes tons of sense let's just go about
this oh yeah
it seemed perfectly normal and nice nice
bread on the counter there was this a
bathtub in the middle of the kitchen
that's a good place for it what's this
magical creature over here Oh is there
another note hang on I got a look at
this guy hello little bloody you have no
face and you're kind of disgusting give
me your best dinner how about you cook
your own damn dinner you douche fine
I'll make you a dinner later
look this is your house your friend Opa
Opa lives with you he's acting strange
sometimes but you love him like a woman
what about a man your boss tried to call
you on the phone but it was on airplane
mode listen take a look outside I'm sure
the weather is good you can drink the
water next time if you're either no like
this please speak very dramatically got
it
regards your mushroom from the inside
alright this is starting to make sense
I'm starting to get a bigger picture of
what's going on here hey you want me to
make dinner right oh you go you're not
talking to me anymore
are you oppa oppa you oppa oppa so I
need to make you dinner Oh Bobo how
about no how about you make your own
damn dinner you son of a [ __ ] you've
been mooching off me for years eating my
stuff in the fridge that's clearly been
liable for haha okay wasn't expecting a
jump-scare here but hi hello mr.
crocodile you look familiar
no no how about yes No
how about yes okay fine first lesson
first lesson
Vash Lawson well where am I gonna find
an unusual amnesia key hmm well this
seems so strange however it can't be too
far I mean this place isn't exactly big
I'm just at a complete loss as to what
is going on here hello are you a
creature can you go die please like the
rest of this that needs to die pretty
much everything in here it's just an
abnormal cluster poop of random-ass
stuff I love the music it's so
fantastical in every way do I have I
don't even have anything in my inventory
fantastic boy i hi never mind I'm not
even gonna try to reason with any of
this I don't even know what this is this
is your dinner hey you want to eat this
yeah good job
Oh papa yo yo yo yo ho papa do good all
right over but just spit out the annual
Oba Oba Oba Oh bah boppa seriously oppa
give me your damn key now give me a
monkey so I can have babies
what does it even mean what do you want
a freaking monkey where am I gonna get a
monkey you didn't even give me anything
did you give me a key
I can't help you if you don't help bees
there's laosan nope okay oh hello hey
look it's a monkey
you want some babies here have your damn
monkey oh yeah you're a frickin weirdo
you son of a gun yeah that's good stuff
do your little flip and get me out of
here okay what was that oh hello you
made babies congratulations this is the
key to your door is it is it really such
lust bus awesome how about this one okay
then
oh look rats on the ground aren't they
strange I have no idea okay this is
totally normal right now I am just gonna
keep wandering around until I die okay
okay all right all right out right out
right yeah
let's skip on off this custom story I
can't even begin to understand anything
here pecks up unusual amnesia key well
you're damn right that's pretty unusual
hey buddy at all where did you go did
you try to jump after me and scare me I
am not exactly in the mood to be scared
right now
I mean that crocodile was kind of
startling but I mean I'm just so
flabbergasted as to what is going on and
tried to that is not what I picked up
okay
you picked up your driving keys what
what what I'm I don't even understand
any part of this but then again maybe I
just need to turn into stupid mode look
he's gay I'm gonna get it I'm gonna get
it all right Justin Bieber is cool
yellow swag sure I don't want to let my
IQ drop too far I am you know me
somewhat smart right
okay this is a little test large is that
the earthbound music hi there how's it
going friend you doing good you're doing
good
other than this whole thing being
absolutely completely messed up I will
say that whoever made it put a whole lot
of work into it because it's not easy to
see it's not easy to just import all
these models Indonesia let alone get
them to animate so they did a good job I
guess if you want to call it that so
good job great great job there hands
straight you've done a good job I'm
really happy for you and everything that
you've done good I really need to play
this did you guys really need to suggest
it to me that much I got like 15 emails
you're saying you gotta play it you
gotta play it I mean I'm not saying it's
not a masterpiece but I could've gone
without madness let's see what else you
got
[Music]
and off the edge of the world we went
good good good glad to know we just fell
off the face of the earth all right what
have we got here wait a minute this
looks semi familiar rolling around at
the speed of sound got places to go
gotta follow my rhythm Oh guess what
lies ahead one way to find out forget it
follow my plan and he's dead
trusting in what you can't see take my
lead I'll set you free follow me set me
free trust me and we will escape from
the city I'll make it through oh god no
no no no no no no no no no not doing any
more of that you had your chance it
sucked and you're a what the hell the
hell hi there you're not supposed to be
in this game something doesn't seem
right here this doesn't seem like normal
engineering work I'm an engineer and
dancing is very rarely involved with you
know engineering work I mean it is
involved but just not to this extent
and definitely not coordinated dancing
what did I do
no son of a [ __ ] you didn't tell me
that was gonna happen
my da da da you didn't tell me that you
were gonna do that
wait what's up there I don't think I can
get up there without something else yeah
okay
this time warn me thank you very much
whatever whatever I don't think there's
a single thing here used from the
original amnesia
besides the engine hello how are you
doing dun-dun-dun-dun
and sank that bottle very crazy I don't
think I will ever get it they betrayed
me
they didn't keep their promise okay all
right all right I believe you know my
name is mark you could actually use the
quote from the movie okey-dokey all
right yeah whatever alright then I'll
ride out ride out right
let me ghost you let me explain your
boss fired you because of a mood don't
let it get you down it's noise what you
hear when the darkest hour has come you
go home now but make sure to explored
your old workplace here there might be
some jelly beans over there in the
toilet
Oh jelly beans in the toilet I want that
oh yeah isn't that yeah I don't know I
don't care let's just find it you a
jelly bean you don't look like a jelly
bean
[Music]
all right as far as everything else I've
seen it here it's not that strange
Oh ki dokie that was great love that all
right I ride out ride out I'll wait hang
on here we go wait a minute there's
something over here there's something to
be explored I can make this jump jump
sweet moves brah swimmers broham okay
going up here gone up here going up here
no don't fall off don't fall off like a
[ __ ] don't fall off thank you very much
okay that fudge it I'm just gonna record
this all in one maybe hello who the hell
are you guys who the hell are you
that's cinnamon toast can let's see I
don't know who these guys are
I wish I did I probably should but I
don't know who they are definitely not
that but that's died I'd recognize that
manly beard anywhere a cinnamon Tufts
can right there sorry I don't know any
of the rest of yourself all right yo who
the hell yo oh wait was this just the
Easter Egg Hall of Fame here okay
alrighty then cool beans okay all right
you know what actually I'm gonna split
this into two parts so I'm gonna finish
this out later so anyway thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]